all right so you probably can tell from
my amazing accent I'm not from here
I'm from the United States of America
uh from Virginia in fact any other
fellow countrymen in the room
Americans no that's what I thought uh do
you see that big boat outside
yeah that was my countrymen actually fun
fact so the Gerald Ford
uh is from Norfolk Virginia which is
where I'm from it's like 20 minutes down
the street
um it's crazy our schedules got
collided like that
um so yeah that's a very big boat and
they built it all like right down the
street from where we live and
commissioned it and now it's
the flagship of the United States Navy
and
I don't want to tell you how much money
we spend on Military
it's way too much no we could put the
better things like
Healthcare
taking care of people we don't do any of
that
I know that would get a laugh in every
country other than America every other
American every American country or um
City would go
yeah yeah you're right there would be no
laughter
uh let's see
uh who's first NDC Oslo hands
that's a good number all right
uh it's mine my first as well I've done
NDC London a handful of times first Oslo
I love to do other ndc's
um so
what do I usually ask here it's hard to
ask questions here like who's who came
the farthest
um did anyone come from a country not in
Europe
all right that narrows it down I had a
gentleman when I did this talk in London
he rose his hand and he said I'm from
South Africa like wow that's a long way
to travel for one conference he's like
no I live here I'm like
you misunderstood the point of the
question sir
all right so well I don't I don't know
all the European countries because I
haven't taken World Geography in
2035 years uh it's been a long time
um
all right so no one outside Europe all
right well that kind of narrows it down
uh who's been to every NDC Oslo I
actually don't know how many they've
ever been so that's a trick question
all right so no hands went up uh who's
been the two NDC oslows
three
four
five
six
seven
oh I have one hand in the back how many
nine ten all right
good job for you sir I I think coming
out to the conferences like this is
amazing
um we don't get this sort of turn out to
anything in the states anymore like
everyone is kind of holed up they work
from home they don't want to go out and
talk to people
um like walking into this expo hall
everyone who's never been to an in DC
also you walk into that room for the
first time it's kind of overwhelming
isn't it just a sheer amount of people
and I walked in at a keynote and it's
like just too many people
I was ready to turn around and walk out
because it was just overwhelming
uh but I am super glad to be here thank
you uh the NDC team for inviting me and
hopefully I can come back in the future
uh as long as y'all don't put red in the
Box maybe I can come back
so let's make a agreement now green
thank you all right
well let's go again get started
um
yeah it's right at time we might as well
get started I have this fascination with
conferences this big because you all
come here and you get to see all these
amazing speakers
and they're up presenting to you and
they're they're doing the hard work
quote hard work but the thing is we're
hardly working at all we I show up for
an hour if I have one session two hours
if I have two sessions and I do a little
Spiel you all learn something new
hopefully and then you go on you go to
the next person hopefully learn
something new
but I'm not working at all I'm just
showing up putting on a smiling face and
I'm presenting the people doing the real
work are like the gentleman over here
doing sound and video
he's doing all this amazing work to make
me look good and hope hopefully sound
good as well and there's folks in every
other room doing this work there's folks
running the
the uh
the over overload room whatever it's
called there's folks down emptying the
trash every single hour there's folks
making sure that you have food to eat
all the time and making sure it's always
good that poor coffee person has to deal
with a line
30 40 50 people long every single hour
there's a lot of work happening in the
background that I don't think we really
appreciate unless we take a step back
from it and that's a very long way of
saying AS application Developers
are yeah I have a tie in here promise uh
our applications kind of work the same
way we hopefully build these really
pretty user interfaces like this I
didn't build this someone else built
this because they have talent and this
is pretty this is what our customers are
coming to this is what our users are
coming to and this does
a lot of work but it's not doing really
anything all is giving us is a list of a
couple items and a place to put in my
payment information
I worked on an app similar to this
a very long time ago early in my career
and we had a workflow for the most
important button on that screen who
wants to guess what it was
a trick question it's the only button on
the screen
the pay now button so the pay now button
is critically important why because it's
how we get paid and it's how the
customer gets whatever crop they're
ordering
so you press the pay now button this is
the way our workflow worked
it would go off and it would do some
stuff in the background create the order
so we could link
items to the order and we would go check
our inventory make sure we have the
stuff in stock there was a process for
that we would charge the credit card and
then we would go off and we would send
an email to the person saying hey we're
all good we're going to get your stuff
shipped out
and come back to the pay now button that
will go away congratulations
everything's great
except
when the email goes out
uh our SMTP is kind of crazy because it
doesn't only work all the time and
our SMTP server had gone down so if you
said pay now create an order check our
inventory charge the credit card send
the email email would
fail
and we would go back to the username
there was an error something wrong bad
happened and uh we had already charged
the credit card
which you're not really supposed to do
unless you have a way of going back to
the customer and tell them everything
was successful so there were cases where
there were repeat orders and because the
people would come back oh let me do this
all over again oh why did I order this
crap three times in a row it's because
our SMTP server was down uh yeah this
not good we shouldn't do it this way
um so hi everyone I'm Kevin and we've
never met before I am the American from
the uh great state of Virginia
I'm an independent consultant Microsoft
MVP I love building applications in
asp.net core uh deploying the Microsoft
Azure and really anything web
development so if you have questions
about any of those things I would love
to chat with you afterwards if you want
to talk to me at the end if I'm not here
uh I have socials here on the screen
I also do a series of courses actually
one that's pertinent to this talk I have
a course called signal on mastery which
if you don't get a photo of it now uh
I'll put in the slack for for everyone
but I'm giving it to you all for free so
that's actually why you want to get the
QR code uh
if you want to do anything real-time web
development signalr Mastery is the best
course available for learning that sort
of stuff everything from web development
to console WPF Maui apps Blazer to a
degree and and I'll teach you how to how
to build them in real time I also have a
course on Hang Fire
so we will actually talk about Hang Fire
in this course and
I just released this course uh not too
long ago so we're slowly building up
some
uh students for it but also free to you
all I'll make sure that information's in
the slack at the very end
all right
let's go back to our scenario
and let's talk about how this process
could have been a little bit better
instead of everything being reliant on
the thing happened before it how could
we redesign this to be a little bit more
resilient to cases where our email
server goes down well let's start with
the pay now button could we pay now
we go off we still want to create order
we want this process to happen and
two things occur first
we go back to the user tell them we have
created your order here's your
confirmation
if you've used any modern e-commerce
site this is what it does
um is Amazon a thing over here
I assume so when you go to Amazon you
order something you never get a hey your
order's been shipped immediately you get
an order confirmation basically saying
we've received your order
we have no idea if you can pay for it we
have no idea if we have it in stock we
have no idea if we can ship it to you in
a timely manner but here's your order
confirmation
at the same time we go off and we do the
other things that we need to do
we check our inventory we charge our
credit card we send our email now if
something happens along the way and we
can't charge the credit card we can then
go back to the customer and tell them
there's a problem fix your payment we'll
restart the workflow
if we can't send the email
SMTP typically just comes back up a
couple minutes later if there's an issue
so we wait and then a couple minutes
later we try sending an email again
but that workflow on the right side of
the screen is independent from the thing
that the customer cares about is that we
have just received the order and we will
deal with everything else a little bit
later in the background
so I uh lost the boom on my thing
okay
uh I did this Workshop a long time ago
uh where we talked about building
production web applications what does it
take to actually take an application
production you go to a conference like
this and you learn a lot of fancy
buzzwords a lot of cool tools but rarely
do they talk about how do you actually
ship something and take it in production
and how do you manage it in production
so we did this workshop and we did this
whole two three hour section on
background tasks and background workers
and we thought we were just preaching to
the choir and turns out not everyone
really understands the various ways
methods methodologies for deploying
background Services
um that kind of inspired me to put this
talk together and buy the room being
full feels like this is something
relevant to everyone potentially
there are two types of background tasks
we're going to talk about the first is
on demand this is the stuff that needs
to occur immediately
but not like at the moment I press the
button so it can wait a second but it
needs to happen as quickly as possible
and typically this is going to be some
sort of workflow
examples from what we've done
transactional emails this is the
important one hey I've received your
your order that's an email that needs to
go out I need to charge your credit card
some sort of payment processing
do I need to go notify other services
that something has occurred if I
uh or notify my own services something's
occurred in the system here I'm going to
send you a hook about it
uh any processing so you put something
new in the database you need to go do
some cleanup on it
we do that sort of work uh kind of on
demand
these are called triggered events
we have other types of background tasks
that happen on some sort of schedule and
we call them reoccurring tasks most
likely
it's going to be something that happens
uh we have all kinds hourly minutely
weekly monthly I used to work on a
system where we had uh was it
bi-annually so like twice a month you
know what happened on some sort of
rotation and this is going to be our
biggest one is reports we want to send a
report to our administrators to our
owners with relevant information that
happens on a schedule
uh
my first uh my first Azure function that
I ever wrote was to clean up resources
in an Azure blob because
all right I'm going to Sidetrack for a
second run a thing put data into a blob
it's like oh it's only a couple hundred
kilobytes not a big deal we'll deal with
that later fast forward like two years
no one laughs okay you know a couple
hundred kilobytes adds up when you're
constantly adding 200 kilobytes at a
time and we got to this point where I'm
like how much stuff is in this blob well
guys it's like oh that's a terabyte of
just text files that we weren't using it
was just redundant data that wasn't
necessary anymore and when you have a
terabyte worth of stuff in Blob storage
it actually costs a little bit of money
like blob storage is fairly free until
you put a lot in there
so we wrote a resource cleanup script
that would just go through and and
delete all that work for us and then
Azure just went and added that as an
option to blob storage which was funny
uh
a couple considerations when you're
figuring out
what type of background process
background servers you want to write
first is where are you going to host it
because it needs to run somewhere that
is
going to work uh make sure it's up and
running
two two obvious places where one you're
running out on your local machine that
might be something like a Windows
service which I
I mentioned Windows services
because
I have done this talk enough times where
people go I write Windows Services all
the time and it's really relevant what
what we talk about in here and they
learned a bunch of new stuff
so that's even I didn't think anyone
wrote Windows Services anymore turns out
a lot of people do
if you're deploying a thick
client application you might want to run
a background service in your thick line
and we'll show you a process for doing
that
I'm assuming a lot of people are
probably web developers in this room
because we kind of take over the world
now but if you're doing web and you're
doing webon.net you're probably
deploying asp.net we can do background
work in our asp.net core apps fairly
easy
and then there's this other Spectrum
where if you're deploying the cloud you
might want to take advantage of cloud
services so we'll talk about Azure
functions and
some ways that we can deploy background
Services there
a couple other things to think about
with background Services figure out what
you want to write it in how you want to
deploy it uh
we talk about resiliency and that
basically means what happens if a task
fails if I have my send email task and
sndp goes down
what happens what happens if it fails
what happens if the service crashes for
any reason we need to be able to recover
from that and some of the tactics we'll
talk about are better than others for
dealing with that sort of thing
so I mentioned the work tactics
because I think the most commonly used
phrase in our industry is it depends
right all right I have a problem can I
use x to solve it well it depends or I
need to do X Y and Z all right well it
depends
because we have that phrase it depends I
want to give you a variety of ways to
solve this problem and you kind of pick
and choose and learn from what makes
sense to you and your application
so the tactics that we're going to try
to cover in the next 50 minutes
are net hosted Services I hosted service
they'll translate into a quick
discussion on Windows Services which is
fascinating if you've ever written
written a Windows service
pre.net core three
it will blow your mind
we'll transition then into asp.net core
hosted services so if you're deploying
asp.net core app
we'll talk briefly about quartz which is
a job scheduling app for or job
scheduling Library for.net which I've
used quite a bit earlier in my career
it's it's great for a very specific set
of purposes we'll talk about what those
are
we'll talk about Hang Fire which I have
a course on which is an amazing tool set
if you just need a GUI and something
that's really hard to mess up
and then finally Azure functions if you
need Cloud scale which I love Cloud
scale so we'll talk about that
all right.net hosted services
who is familiar already with ihosted
service in.net
okay a couple hands good so we're going
to kind of recap what it is and everyone
else you get to learn
so and Dot net I looked this up it
was.net core of two they introduced this
concept called the I hosted service and
the problem that it was trying to solve
was
before
even in.net framework trying to do any
sort of work in the background of a.net
application was very difficult to do you
would you usually had to hack it
together yourself there were a couple
third-party libraries that helped a
little bit but not quite it was just a
difficult job
with uh done in Core 2 and tune in.net
core 3. they introduced this concept of
the I hosted service which allowed us to
Implement many hosted Services inside of
our application
I could have one I could have 10. you
have as many as you want these are
independently managed Services running
in the background of your application
the.net host manages the entire
lifecycle of them automatically for you
so when your application starts up the
hose and service starts up if your
application shuts down gracefully
which hopefully yours do it will shut
down the service gracefully clean up any
any memory or resources that you have
open
if there's a case where
the service fails you can write hook so
it automatically restarts itself it's a
fairly powerful little piece of code
oh here's an example of one this is a
class I've written it implements
background service which
implements I hosted service
and what this is going to do is when the
application starts it's going to call
the execute async method inside my class
and it's going to go off and do work
until
that method ever returns when that
method Returns the service is done it
shuts itself down
now I have a while loop in here that's
just going to go forever until the
application once it shuts shut itself
down gracefully and that's done with the
cancellation token but this is really
useful
and it's just going to go off in the
background it's going to do its own
thing and I have full insight into
my.net application here so I have
dependency injection if you're using
dependency injection which probably are
and
so you can inject all your services do
all your work and this is happening
gracefully in the background
to tell.net that this is the thing
you inject it as a service
so in your startup CS file or your
program CS depending on what flavor.net
you're using nowadays
you have a section somewhere where you
configure services
and you add
hosted service
of whatever type that you create so
clean up folder service
now what's really cool about this is
that this I hosted service isn't
dependent on being a web app it's not
dependent on being the console app or
WPF or Maui or whatever thing in the.net
Universe you're using
it works across all of them if they
support I host which most of them do
I want to show you Windows service
because I had a use case back in 23rd
2012 2013 where we're building a Windows
service on.net and this is before.net
core had really uh picked itself up and
if you've ever ridden a Windows service
in.net framework
there were two ways to do it there was
the hard way which I did was you had to
write all the hooks for Windows service
yourself manually which basically means
you handle command line arguments what
does slash S do what does slash C do and
the documentation for writing that sort
of stuff wasn't very good and you learn
most of it from Forum posts from 10
years prior there's also a package out
there called top shelf which was amazing
and I didn't learn about it
until I had written all by hand that's
the story of my life
but
with.net core
or now just.net we have this new service
called hosting dot Windows services
so you install this package and then in
your application
it's literally this is technically one
line of code use Windows service
give it a name set a couple options on
it
and now this will automatically take
care of all the windows service stuff
underneath the scenes
why don't we do a demo
so I have a code here this will all be
available for you in slack when we're
all done but this is
uh basically what you just saw here on
the slide we have an application we're
going to set up a Windows service called
the Tactical Windows service
and we're going to use a I hosted
service called cleanup folder service
I'm going to say service a lot once the
cleanup folder service does it cleans up
a folder
so we look at the code here I made a
couple tweaks of this since first time I
wrote it but every couple seconds
it's going to go check out temporary
folder and see if there are any files in
it
if there are any files in there that are
older than five seconds we're going to
delete the file
all right that's it
let's go to the command line we're going
to say dot net run
give it a second there we go
so this is checking a folder called seed
temp
I'm going to go that folder right now
and I have zoom it for y'all
and what we're going to do is we're
going to add a new file folder to it new
file to it we'll just call it new word
doc then we're going to wait a moment
for the delay
which I think I set the 15 seconds but
we'll give it a moment all right
so I found one file delete it delete the
folder cool let's do a background word
that's not Applause Worthy
you all I say is no one Applause
all right that's not impressive at all
uh I'm going to show you something
that's impressive
so let's take that same application and
I'm going to copy some clip notes real
fast
um
I'm going to
scroll down
and we're going to create a Windows
service now if you've never created a
Windows service before
you open up a new command prompt as
administrator
and
I'm going to paste this code
and then I have to
then go get the path of my
publish so we'll say
net publish
so it was currently published too
ah there we go
and let's see it's called tactics
dot exe before I do that
let's open up my services page
I'm going to scroll down you'll see that
there's nothing called tactics in here
yep nothing called tactics
all the t's
all right we'll go back hopefully I type
that all in correctly with enter success
success is good
we go back to our services hit refresh
scroll down you see uh the tactic that
Windows services
now I have it set to manually start
we'll give that a second it's now
running in the background
doing the same thing that I was doing
before
we'll go back to our temp folder
we'll create another file
we'll do a PowerPoint presentation now
and we again just wait a couple seconds
anywhere between
now and 15 seconds
and the one problem is I don't have the
logging inside here if I cared about
logging from my Windows service I could
log to
Event Source so I can get it from
Windows directly but normal file
it's because it was all done by the
windows service now that is a pause
Worthy
don't give me your pity Applause
I saw all right I'm going to worry about
deleting that later we're going to shut
it off for now
um
now I do that demo I was going to take
this demo out but I've had at least
three people come up and go that was
super useful I didn't know we could do
that in.net I have a use for that
tomorrow
if you're that boring too
awesome I'm glad I could help let's move
on to the next thing
actually a couple of pros and cons of
Windows Services uh first they're really
easy to build if you've ever built a
Windows service in.net framework compare
that to this it's a night and day
difference
uh windows will automatically manage the
lifecycle for you so if your windows
this nice thing about Windows Services
if your windows service crashes the
service scheduler is going to
automatically turn it back on
um and if it constantly keeps crashing
you can go into the error logs and see
what the problem might be this is useful
the con is it's limited to the machine
or the server that you're running it on
so if you're scaling this at any
capacity you're responsible for going
setting up those windows services
uh this is useful for
well it's not really useful for
on-demand work this is probably a little
bit better for scheduled work that's
going to happen or if you're watching
folders or if you're watching any sort
of external stimulus to to execute the
action
uh if you're trying to do work on demand
it's you have to do all the heavy
lifting it's not very done for you
you're also responsible for resiliency
of individual tasks so if I have it if
my task for cleaning up the folders has
an issue in it and it fails
it's my responsibility to go put a try
catch around it or to do some sort of
other work
common question I get is Kevin that's
great if I'm running on Windows but what
if I'm running on Linux turns out
there's the exact same thing for Linux
so if you can run under system D you can
install the systemd package you change
the line that says use Windows services
to use systemd
Tada it should work I have not actually
tested yet I've just put the slide in
here
but
everything I'm told says one line of
code change after you have this package
it should work on Linux as well so cool
let's transition away from Windows
Services into
asp.net core apps uh if who's ASP online
core developer
all right that's what I like to see
all right aspl net core
we can take the exact same background
Services I host and service and we can
bring it over to our application
so this is a Net 7 app using that new
funky single file syntax that they all
like uh does anyone like that
single file the one hand
doesn't confuse the recipe you're like
give me my classes I was just one of my
classes where's my program CS all right
doesn't matter
we still are using an eye host so it's
the iweb host and I'm implementing uh ad
hosted service my cleanup temp folder
service and it does the exact same thing
when the application starts
the hosted service automatically starts
does its thing until the application
crashes or shuts down gracefully
let's show that as a demo
the exact same app
this time at the asp.net core
and you can see here my map kit said
hello world
I've taken the exact same background
service that we had in the previous
example uh
yes exact same should be the exact same
code
and I'm adding as a hosted service for
asp.net core
so now
if I go in say.net run
if I spell it correctly
and we wait a moment so we can tell
we're running especi core because I can
open a browser and it says hello world
yay
but in the background the
little Watcher is running and it's
waiting for some
some files to get added up my temp
folder is in a different place that's
the one thing I changed
just to show I'm not reusing services
I'm going to add a new file
which is a text file this time
and we'll sit here and wait all right
just ran delete the folder or the file
file is gone yeah
cool
the impressive part isn't that delete
the file the impressive part is I just
reused the code that I written
originally so if I'm writing a lot of
these Services I can share them across
multiple applications if I need to if I
have a case where that's required now we
talk so much about reusability in our
code this is actual reusability I can
use it everywhere
but I think it's super useful
doesn't solve one or two core problems
uh big Pro go again easy to build
runs inside of our ESPN core application
yay everyone's happy uh I'm gonna
automatically starts when the
application starts up cool
uh there's a couple fundamental cons
we can't really do anything with
scheduling here this is the same problem
that we had when it was a Windows
service if I was scheduling any sort of
tasks that needed to happen I had to
write that scheduling myself let me
check the time every iteration of the
while loop or I get set of my own timers
there's various ways I can solve that
problem I actually want to show you
Quartz in a moment which solved that
problem a little bit easier better
in my opinion
again you're responsible for resiliency
if that hosted service crashes for any
reason
it just stops you have to restart it
some other way
so it's it's up to you to do a little
bit more of the heavy lifting they're
giving you the framework to build the
services on
all right let's move on to quartz now
who uh who's never heard of quartz
before
all right that's that's the number of
hands I was going that's a good number
so quartz is really cool
service for setting up
um
we have jobs and we have triggers and if
you need High precision timing and
scheduling of different uh jobs in your
application
quartz works really well here uh and it
works again across any type of.net
application you might want to run
the the only fog drawback is it's a lot
of code that just implements something
simple in my opinion if you look at the
code on the left
we're creating two two concepts first we
have the job this is the work that we
want to do
and so I'm creating a job called cleanup
temp folder job
and I'm sending some other parameters
like I want to store it durably so I
want to keep track of when it runs I
want to make sure that it doesn't run
twice in a row at the same time and I'm
adding a description to it
so the job is separate the job will run
whenever I tell it it is supposed to run
that could be on demand that could be on
some sort of schedule
so the snippet below it I'm sending up a
cron task every 30 seconds
I want to go run that job and make sure
it runs on a recurring schedule
since I'm running this inside of asp.net
core I also have to add the bit on the
right for in the court server this also
gives me a little bit of dependency
injection as well
still a pain about the setup but when it
runs runs gloriously
this is what a quartz job looks like you
have to implement their eye job you
can't just use your own code or use
anything that Microsoft's written so
your vendor locking a little bit to
quartz when you go this route
but you can get dependency injection and
you fill in the blank with the execute
method when this job runs for any reason
let's go do some stuff
so I take the same concept that we
talked about before I had to rewrite it
because it's its own
implementation
so we'll show you program first this is
the snippet I just had on the screen
will create the job and we'll create the
trigger so every third every 15 seconds
uh we're going to go run quartz
now I have a separate service for quartz
server what's really cool here is if I'm
backing this as some sort of data store
um like redis or SQL server or you name
it I could have
my web server and my job server separate
so the web server can issue tasks that
need to be done
and the job server does them as they
come in or as they need to get run this
is really nice because it doesn't bog
down your web server
this is the con that I should have put
into the aspi course slide if I have 15
hosted Services running in side of my
asp.9 core app well that's going to take
some resources away from my asp.9 core
app so if I'm going for
a massive number of requests per second
that might be slightly limited by then
if I have a lot of heavy lifting hosted
services
if I have a separate job server that's
doing all this work I don't have to
worry about that my web server can just
be a web server my court server can just
be a job server
the cleanup temp folder
similar but like I said you have to
implement ijob their implementation
and you have to use their interface so
I'm executing the job when it occurs
going to a directory getting files and
deleting the files as I see them
bless you
if I go to dot net run
so this is my web app with quartz
all right so this is running this is
looking at cleanup temp folder service
again
yep
I'm going to create another file we'll
create an access database nobody won't
because I don't want to actually run
no one willingly opens access anymore
all right let's create a word doc here
we go
let's uh we'll let that sit there for a
minute what did I say 15 seconds
wait about 15 seconds the court shop is
going to execute and it should delete
that file boom everything's good
so
um
you're probably going to do like way
more complicated stuff with these
systems than I am but I have written
this code before the just go clamp a
folder go clean up a resource
because you might accidentally put a
terabyte worth of stuff in there and
forget about it
let's close that out
so moving along
uh big Pro of quartz
is you get very precise scheduling and
timing so if I tell that job I needed to
run every half hour on half hour it's
going to run every half hour if I need
it to run at nine in the evening every
Sunday night
it's going to run at 9 00 PM every
Sunday night or uh what does that
translated your time to 2100 yeah yeah
yeah I can do math
unless I was wrong then I can't but it
will do precise scheduling if you need
something happening immediately you can
do on-demand trigger say do this job now
and we'll go off and do the job now
oh that's what the bullet Point's for I
really like the separate job server
concept and I think
I should have more slides dedicated to
that Concept in general because a lot of
this work you probably don't want to do
on your main web application you want to
have it somewhere separate
because you don't want to you want the
web server to be the web server or
talked about that have a separate job
server that does all the work you can
scale it independently so if you need
more job servers to handle load you
create more job servers
a couple cons I don't like vendor lock
to a degree using quartz jobs you're
vendor locked so unless you're
abstracting out and the job is just
calling into your own abstraction
you're you're locking in the courts
that's all right and for most of us for
99 of us that's okay it's not a big deal
um
I also don't like their process for
tying into.net dependency injection
every other library in.net has gotten
that part right nowadays courts hasn't
courts needs you to install a whole
separate package and you write a handful
of lines of configuration every other
Library out there just works so
but no big deal but it's a small con B
uh worried about
all right Hang Fire I came to Hang Fire
a very long time ago and it's been in
probably
every application I've written for the
past
10 years that's probably a rough
estimate
um Hang Fire if you all right show our
hands here who's
not her to Hang Fire not her to hang
fire all right more than quartz so more
people have heard of course all right
I'm about to blow your minds
probably not but all right courts are
Hang Fire
same idea we have jobs that run on
either on demand or on some sort of
schedule and what's really cool about
hang fires you can add these fancy uis
to your web apps so you can track the
jobs being done uh this is most
synonymous any uh rails developers in
here
no not single rails developer awesome
disregard anything I'm about to say uh
so rails have this uh system called
sidekick
and it's like one guy I wrote this
application makes 10 million dollars a
month on it and it does What Hank fire
does and I'm super jealous of him uh but
ink buyer is for.net what Sidekick is
the rails and it's just a job Runner
with a fancy UI and does all this really
cool stuff
we'll see that part in a moment uh the
implementation is your own code
if you write a class notice there's no I
of anything there's no implementing an
app check class it's just cleanup temp
folder job this is my own code it's my
own methods
then
when I configure Hang Fire
we see I have a line here it says
reoccurring job
I'm telling it to add or update an
existing job if it's already there
that's I want to go execute my class
called execute or My Method called
execute every 30 seconds
or down in
I guess it's easier to point I can't
really Point here can I uh
yes I can can I do this
no no I'm not gonna do that uh inside my
map get I have a call to generate
and that schedules
a call later for the generate method
so I'm telling Hang Fire these are the
things I want to go run these are all my
own classes is using the strengths of
c-sharp and generics and all that good
stuff too say all right give me your
types and I'll execute the meth methods
on your own types there's nothing
special to implement elsewhere
this will make more sense in code so
let's jump over to
our Hang Fire
program
there's a whole bunch of stuff in here
but let's just talk about the important
pieces
so I have a temp job
class again not implementing anything
I'm using
.net dependency injection
and I have these two methods execute and
generate
and these are my own methods I could
call them Foo I could call them bar I
can call them Steve I can call them
whatever I want to it doesn't matter
from these two methods the only thing
that's required is that they're public
so Hang Fire can access them later
they can be asynchronous if I need them
to be asynchronous
then from various parts of my
application
I can inject What's called the
background job client
and the background job client is just my
connection to Hang Fire and I tell it
all right please go run the temp folder
job for me now we'll go do that
or I'm sorry the generate or here's a SK
a schedule example so maybe I don't want
to do it now maybe I want to do it in 15
seconds or a couple hours from now I can
schedule jobs that happen at a later
time
I also have this concept of the
dashboard
so if I want the fancy UI for hangfire I
just add one line of code I now have a
fancy UI
if we run this
.net run
one thing you might notice here at the
top it's installing SQL Server objects
uh the
piece I left out at the beginning is
that you have to have some sort of
backing store for Hang Fire to persist
over time
by default that's expected to be SQL
Server
so you can server is great there's a
couple caveats with SQL server but it
works well enough you could also use any
relational database in my course I use
SQL Lite I use MySQL
and SQL Server they all work well you
could also use redis if you're willing
to pay for it that's really smart of the
Hang Fire folks because they pay for the
better data store
but SQL Server works well enough
so it automatically installs itself into
SQL Server if you give it a connection
string
and you see here it's running a
reoccurring job
but I'm going to open my
Edge let me find my
my browser and
by default you go to slash Hang Fire
this brings up the Hang Fire UI
and we'll blow this up a little
now a couple things of interest here you
have the jobs that have run
you see here's every job that's run on
my application and
it tells you when it ran how long it
take to run and whether or not I was
successful we also have failures if
there were failures but my code doesn't
crash so it's not a problem uh hey I got
a couple checks we can get a full
um
basically job log of any job that's
running at the time so here I see that
the job was queued uh again various
named cues with different priorities
when was it processed how long did it
take to process did succeed or fail if
it fails for any reason it'll
automatically retry up to 10 times and
it'll tell me every time it's retried
even better up here at the top it tells
you
the call that was made to to execute the
method so if I have parameters so X Cube
might take three or four parameters if
it did uh it would show me all the
parameters it would tell me what the
values of those parameters were at the
time the job is called
I can switch over to reoccurring tasks
so this is everything that's going to
run on some sort of schedule every 30
seconds
when was the last time it was executed
when's it going to execute again
I'm cheating a little bit because I
created this demo four months ago
and I forgot to delete the database
but I could run these on demand too if I
need this to run now
let's run
we had a issue the other day
put on our applications uh my one of the
guys in my team did deploy and he broke
one of the Hang Fire jobs and we didn't
know about it until the next morning so
we had 80 failed jobs which doesn't seem
like a big number but
to the customers that we affected it was
a big number
so uh we were able to actually go in
push our fix go back and rerun all the
failed jobs and it was like nothing ever
happened doing that in any of our other
services would have been a pain in the
butt
any fire made it very easy
we also have multiple servers at any one
time I'm probably running three or four
different servers just job workers for
for heavy lifting we can also prioritize
stuff but I'm not going to talk about
all that right now
let me show you
a
what it's actually doing so I think it's
cleanup temp folder job
now I have a handy little method here
called generate
no it's not generated what is it
oh generate now generate later yeah
so we're going to say generate now
this is going to go off and probably run
very quickly
and there's a whole bunch of files in
there I think I tell it to generate 100
files
and we're going to wait a moment
let's put these side by side up I was
too slow
it deleted all the files
so that's one way to do it
I could also say generate later
now this is going to schedule a job so
we see generate the same method just
running at a different time
it's going to run in a few seconds
we can go look at it
it's enqueued
there we go so it ran
succeeded
and actually
it ran and immediately the cleanup job
ran after it so yay it's working as
intended
but this is really useful if you just
you like having the UI knowing when
these jobs run BM will go back look at
the history of jobs when they run very
useful for all those use cases we have
used Hang Fire heavily in a lot of our
applications that's why
uh that's why I like talking about it
here
there are a couple pros and cons to it
though
you get that precise scheduling and
timing like you did with quartz so if it
doesn't run when it's supposed to it's
going to catch up as soon as it can
it's much easier to run
-off jobs when you need them to
I also like that our jobs are strongly
types we're not beholden to courts and
their particular implementation of a job
we can write our code or bring in our
existing code and just add it to Hank
Byron works exactly the way that we
wanted to the UI is it's amazing to have
a UI the UI is not amazing because it's
bootstrap
that did not get a laugh okay I'm sorry
I offended boot shot people
uh the big con is that you have to use
SQL server or some sort of relational
database behind the scenes
if you want the really good performance
paywall or a data store it's behind the
paywall which I don't think is a huge
con because we've architected around the
the issues with SQL Server
and most of the big issues have been
around just
Hang Fire had a bug once a couple years
ago it's been fixed where it would use a
hundred percent utilization on SQL
server and we were running on SQL azure
and actually took down our production
database because our took down our
production system because we had two
systems both talking to the same
database
and uh yeah that was a fun afternoon
what we ended up doing was just using a
different database just for Hang Fire
jobs and solved all of our problems
we did set up a separate job server for
hangfire which I think is because it's
strongly tied to your code means when
you make a signature change or add a new
method that you need to use in Hang Fire
you have to deploy everywhere not to
just usually the one place that you
would normally care about
again not a big problem especially if
you have some sort of continuous
integration in place
but something to be aware of
um that's it that's that's why I have a
course on I'm actually building courses
on all the different tactics Hang Fire
was first because it's my favorite
but again I'll make sure that this is in
slack at the very end I'll wait for the
the cameras
again you all get it for free
camera all the cameras come up
all right let's talk about the the last
tactic and so the the story with this is
we were heavily invested in Hang Fire
and then we hit this point where we were
asking our Hang Fire to do too much and
it was it was actually becoming more
cumbersome the right our background
tasks for
for a Hang Fire then it would be and we
need we needed more scale like it wasn't
a big deal with Hang Fire to process
like 100 200 entities you just create
those jobs and goes off but we were
starting to hit workflows where we
needed the process four million entities
and Hang Fire could do it
but we were really hitting that wall of
we needed more processing power and what
we really needed was Cloud scale so
we're deploying all of our stuff to
Azure we had taken a look at using Azure
services to do a lot of this work for us
and
I used to be in the boat of
you know serverless is not serverless
it's someone else's servers I'm just
borrowing it and I'm if you're out there
and you're not in your head you probably
agree with me it's like serverless is
just a fad serverless changed I
something clicked in me and I
radically changed my opinion of
serverless and I want to use it for all
the things now it is my new hammer
so what's really cool about Azure
functions and this is not a serverless
talk it's just talking about Azure
functions in general
is that I can take the same concepts for
background tasks so I have things that
need to happen immediately I need to
happen happen on some sort of schedule
or I need them to happen with some sort
of event occurs Azure functions is
basically that as a platform where I
have something I need to run on some
sort of timer so or some sort of
schedule
and if I'm using chronic it's say every
30 seconds I need something to execute
oh this is really cool this is going to
do the exact same thing I was doing in
Hank fire or in quartz
Etc except it's in Azure functions
and it's scalable so if I need to scale
this out across 20
different notes it'll do that for me
automatically
and I have way more options in terms of
triggers than I did with stuff like
hangfire
this is meant to be unreadable because
it's a very long list so if I want to
listen for changes in my blob storage I
could do that and automatically execute
some code if I'm let's see let's go down
a list
I'm listening to a queue and I need to
process stuff as they get popular into a
queue I can do that if
I care about timers looking at table
storage or a rabbitmq there's triggers
for all kinds of different Services you
can also write your own triggers so if
you have your own services and you want
to write jobs that run when certain
events occur you can write your own
trigger
there's a new one for SQL Server if you
want to execute an Azure function when a
table row gets updated or inserted
automatically runs an Azure function
that's crazy powerful in my opinion
so let's go look at a very basic
Azure function
and then we'll wrap up for any questions
you all might have so this one's very
simple it's a timer trigger it's not
cleaning up anything because that was
way harder to do in Azure functions
um and what this is doing is every 30
seconds it's going to go uh to the web
it's going to get a list of articles on
my website it's going to pull them down
and it's going to drop them into a blob
for me
so nothing special
Let's Open up The Blob
let's delete what's already in there
we'll say this is a different command
this is Funk start
now I have another talk I did didn't get
it selected by NDC but it's called
annihilating workloads with Azure
functions and we show a use case where
we have four million entities that if we
just had a standard process like a for
each Loop going through them it would
take hours and hours and hours to
process all these different entities If
I Had A multi-core system that was
processing the same Loop parallel it
would still take a couple hours to do
all this work but we drop into an Azure
function
and we populate a q with the same
workload it knocks it out in 30 seconds
I am
very much an advocate for for cloud
scale and Powerful power power here
so I had a timer trigger so a background
task to run every 30 seconds you can see
it goes off and executes
in HTTP request
and we could
see oh I got the file in I'm not going
to bother opening the file just showing
you that it's happening every 30 seconds
like we expected to
and I could have
triggers for a variety of other
processes and they all work the exact
same way
so again the pros and cons
again for precise scheduling and timing
actually even more so that there's a
concept in Azure functions timers it's
um basically if the timer doesn't
execute when it's supposed to it's
immediately going to try it's going to
catch up when it can and it'll tell you
I'm running the timer out of sync but
it's because it never ran previously
and if your timer trigger fails for any
reason it's going to automatically come
back and retry the trigger again
there's dozens of trigger options out
there ways to execute code when things
happen that's kind of the whole point
here is when something happens whether
it's a certain time elapses or an event
occurs I need to go do some work
the biggest benefit of azure functions I
get Cloud scale so if I need to do a lot
of work
at a moment's notice I have the cloud
available to me but when I don't need
that resource it's not something I'm
using it's not something I'm paying for
it just kind of goes away so I can scale
up and down uh as gracefully as I need
to
the tasks are independently resilient so
if I have a a timer Trigger or if I have
some other sort of job like a q trigger
if it fails for any reason it's
automatically going to retry to run a
job again
and it's going to retry a certain number
of times and then it fails but it fails
in a way where I can detect the failure
and go see what the issue might be retry
the preload if if I want to
the biggest con this is the biggest con
is that there's an Azure requirement so
if you're on AWS you know you got Lambda
and I'm only like three percent
you know aware what's in Lambda I'm an
Azure guy but you know there are other
serverless platforms out there that do
very similar things so whether or not
you're using Azure yay but if you're
using something else
is probably a way that you can solve the
same problem
uh the biggest conclusion from all this
is
just make sure you're doing work in the
background if you have anything that's
heavy lifting you need to do a lot of it
don't do this on anything that might
potentially affect the user or the
customer so don't give them that that
error page that something went wrong
when it was something that should have
been done in background to begin with
the user experience should be pretty
straightforward click the button
something happens click the button
something happens if there's an issue
that's going to occur
let it occur somewhere else somewhere
that we can control
control what happens
the user even if it fails the user
should still get a thumbs up and that
positive experience unless it's
something that they need to fix
immediately
um but all that said I'm going to hang
out for a couple minutes
and then clear out for the next speaker
I am happy to answer any questions you
have thank you all so much
[Applause]